[Musique]
enfin
si vous êtes un amateur de bonne cuisine
vous connaissez forcément notre invité
c'est un jeune prodige de la gastronomie
française sa première étoile il l'a eu a
moins de 30 ans et il l'a obtenue dès
que son établissement a ouvert son resto
est à paris mais sa cuisine et tourné
vers le monde d'inspiration japonaise
françaises africaines d'ailleurs le nom
qu'il a choisi et évocateur mot souquet
mot pour mot riz son prénom à lui et
souquet pourriez souk est le seul
samouraï africain de l'histoire chez lui
vous mangerez donc un boeuf de l'aubrac
façons m'as fait un homard au barbecue
japonais sauce miso ou une ganache au
chocolat et glace au wasabi et oui sa
cuisine est sans frontières les produits
de la planète il ne les fusionne pas il
les fait converser ils relèvent leurs
saveurs en les faisant discuté dans nos
assiettes considère-t-il alors la
gastronomie comme un instrument de paix
de réconciliation entre les peuples
c'est un peu ambitieux mais pourquoi pas
posez lui la question bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenus maurice aco et
merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui dans
ce dom tournant au sénat j'ai un peu dur
avec vous je commence avec une question
un peu sérieuse un peu gras presque
philosophique mais sérieusement est-ce
que la cuisine est effectivement un
instrument de paix pour vous qui
rassemble les gens et donc aussi les
peuples et les cultures bah oui tout
simplement
ben c'est pour moi totalement c'est ya
pas de meilleur moyen pour moi de
découvrir une culture c'est ce n'est que
de la manger littéralement quand on
fasse autour de la table et qu'on
partage un repas avec qui que ce soit et
que cette personne a envie d'échanger
envie de montrer un peu de soi bas
généralement on a envie de faire une
recette qu'on connaît bien une recette
qui nous qui montre un peu qu'ils en
aient fait c'est échanger se construit
beaucoup plus facilement donc 8 la table
et l'assiette sans un instrument de paix
est un instrument surtout de découverte
et de curiosité énorme et d'ailleurs je
lisais que depuis 2010 le repas
gastronomique français est inscrit au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco est il et
il y est défini je cite comme pratique
sociale coutumière destinée à célébrer
les moments les plus importants de la
vie des individus et des groupes tels
que naissances mariages anniversaires
succès et retrouvailles c'est pas rien
quand même vous êtes le représentant de
ça est ce que vous et une conscience de
la responsabilité vous avez du rôle
social que vous avez la responsabilité
en fait moi je n'avais pas forcément
conscience à voir mais je pense que le
confinement nous a fait prendre
conscience de du rôle du restaurant
finale qui n'était pas juste de un lieu
où on mange mais c'est vraiment un lieu
où on se retrouve un lieu en échange est
un lieu où on célèbre la vie du tout
vraiment mais où il se passe toujours
quelque chose donc on va pas en restant
juste pour manger on va au restaurant
pour tout ce qui est à côté au final est
en fait ce moment a été un moment
charnière de votre parcours
professionnel à ce moment là vous avez
compris votre rôle ouais totalement moi
j'ai compris mon rôle est surtout que
j'ai vécu en deux phases et le premier
où j'allais ouvrir mon restaurant et
finalement on a dû reporter donc j'ai
plus de temps pour réfléchir mais j'ai
pu voir les collègues se débattent s'est
démené pour faire d'autres choses et la
deuxième partie j'ai été directement
impactés puisque j'ai ouvert mon
restaurant on a dû se réinventer et on a
pu échanger avec les clients justement
qu'ils venaient chercher leurs plats à
emporter mais qui ne disaient c'est
génial on est content venir vous voir
prendre un peu ce que vous faites mais
on a juste hâte de venir s'installer
récent à découvrir totalement donc
affronter qui avait cette expérience a
fait incomplète et ce moment là beaucoup
aidé et quand vous voyez ces restaurants
en asie notamment où effectivement il ya
des plexiglas maintenant entre les
convives c'est un peu terrible vous
craignez pour l'avenir de de la
restauration cette convivialité à la
table d'un resto alors j'ai eu peur un
moment quand j'ai vu les pepsi arrivé et
tout mais finalement on voit bien que
non et c'est tant mieux et non je pense
que le restaurant n'a pas de grande
inquiétude à se faire tant que les gens
auront besoin de manger il y aura des
restaurants nom sera là pour faire à
manger dans des restaurants alors on va
revenir sur votre parcours
il est passionnant et on va y rester
vraiment quelques minutes chez vous
quand vous étiez petit en seine et marne
c'était votre maman qui préparait à
manger et c'était apparemment que des
plats africains partager en famille de
grands moments des changes avec vos
parents et vos huit frères et soeurs est
ce que vous diriez que c'est un peu le
point de départ de votre vocation de
votre goût pour la cuisine c'est un peu
le point de départ mais à ce moment-là
ça perd mon insu
in je me présente absolument pas là
dedans mais c'est vrai que cette
célébration en fait autour du repas
permanente et surtout ce goût du bon
parce que ma mère cuisine est super bien
et donc tout ce qu'on mange et boit
c'était très bon donc tu fais pas ça va
fêter mon goût pour les bonnes choses et
pour ces petites retrouvailles et ces
moments partagés autour de la table
votre mère et sénégalo-malienne votre
père est malien votre mère de cuisine et
que des plats africains et elle avait
elle même appris à cuisiner au cours de
ses voyages dont l'ouest de l'afrique si
j'ai bien compris et ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'à priori la cuisine
française à ce moment là de votre vie
vous ne la connaissez qu'à la cantine
macway ce moment là c'est vrai que j'ai
toutes ses connaissances de ses cuisines
d'afrique de l'ouest et moi la cuisine
française je la connais mais absolument
pas du tout quoi donc j'ai la plus
grande pour moi le club français qu'ils
avaient mangé à ce moment là c'est
peut-être une banquette la cantine ce
qui est peut-être
française mais je n'avais pas d'autres
et à ce moment là ça vous dégoûte pas de
la cuisine française que vous manger à
la cantine française alors ça ne donne
pas un avis forcément positif
vous qu'à ce moment-là je me dis moi
c'est quand même meilleure ce qui va
vers prépare donc c'est pas ma curiosité
pas forcément piqué est alors votre
histoire avec la france elle est un peu
différente de celle de vos frères et
soeurs ce que vous êtes le sixième de
votre fratrie mais vous êtes le premier
à être né en france
vous avez tous vécu quelques temps
séparés les uns des autres avant que vos
frères et soeurs nous rejoignent et je
crois que vous avez dix ans quand votre
famille est vraiment au complet et vous
grandissez à tournan en brie alors c'est
l'ile-de-france pour ceux qui nous
regardent et qui ne connaîtraient pas
signalé de cross mais c'est quand même
un peu la compagnie vous êtes entouré
votre site et elle est entourée de
champs ouais c'est ça c'est on est sur
l'image c'est le terminus uae donc on
est vraiment à la fin et donc on allait
chez l'homme mais on en prend le vélo 10
minutes et d'art c'est que deschamps
pendant sur 10 20 km quoi donc
donc c'est un peu une enfance pour moi
qui aie qui est heureuse mais qui aussi
décapante parce que je suis en même
temps on est à trente minutes de
l'arrière de paris mais en même temps je
prends le vélo 10 minutes et je suis
dans des champs donc j'ai grandi dans
ses divers importante et de santé alors
enfant de la ruralité ou enfants urbain
jc monde et les deux au final et les
deux parce que moi j'ai des jets les
plaisirs simples qui était bas comme
tout jeune en ile-de-france prendre le
rer à les acheter puis en janvier potes
ça fait partie j'avais bien la ville
voilà mais il y avait aussi les faire
des barbecues milieu d'un champ âgés de
16 ou on pourrait même pas situer on a
zéro réseau donc il ya ces deux choses
au final et j'ai vécu entre les deux
donc moi dd2 pour moi c'est pas un
problème de jouer de jongler avec avec
un petit goût de terroir avec déjà une
idée de ce qu'est le produit naturel la
nature un goût pour la nature ou pas
déjà à ce moment là bas un goût pour la
nature oui parce que final le fait
d'avoir grandi dans cette ville par
exemple pas chose commune mais non l
école primaire en fait de l'équitation
créances hors pair ont visité des
fromageries parce que bon on est
pendante plein dans le pays briard donc
on fabrique le brie de meaux le brie de
melun le biais d'un kaunas contact aussi
qui est entretenue par l'éducation
nationale où on ne fait visiter en fait
tous ses savoir faire qui sont du
terroir et donc au final même quand on
est jeune bon ça nous ennuie fortement
au final à la fin se souvient encore et
à bas maintenant ça ne sert énormément
d'amis j'imagine alors le mali est aussi
extrêmement présent dans votre quotidien
on l'a vu dans la nourriture mais sait
il est aussi présent dans l'est la
langue que vous parlez avec vos parents
dans la musique que vous écoutez dans le
monde qui vient à la maison vous avez
dit un jour c'était comme dans les
villages africains le monde venait à la
maison comme ça est ce que vous vous
sentiez - français pour autant d'avoir
le mal ici présents comme ça dans votre
quotidien ou pas moi non parce que
finale pour moi c'était une addition
c'est je le disais pas récent et 70 30
noms au final c'est je le sentais
français avec le frère et soeur en
parler français en sorte et on avait la
même vie que n'importe quel autre
français mais en plus j'avais tout ce
mode de vie
baala malienne où j'avais des oncles et
tantes qui débarquait à la france quelle
heure il y avait toujours quelqu'un à la
maison il avait toujours à manger
quelque part sur la table et ça veut
dévier au final qui est une addition à
ce que je connaissais déjà au final donc
oui les cultures séditieux mais elle ne
s'élimine pas les uns les autres patchs
d'affaires y avait pas de choix à faire
non il n'y a absolument aucun choix à
faire au final on prend les deux et puis
voilà quoi mais c'est vraiment pour moi
comme ça que je vois les choses au
quotidien ce final c'est une addition et
on est riche de plus mais ça vient pas
ce serait quelque chose et je disais que
vous étiez aussi très ouvert très vite
petit garçon vous avez notamment
d'ailleurs vous disiez vous étiez
passionné d autres cultures des cultures
étrangères et notamment grâce à la
télévision et vous avez dit un jour la
télé était la fenêtre sur tout ce que je
ne pouvais pas connaître c'était la télé
qui vous faisait découvrir ce monde voit
totalement est la télé moi c était pour
moi bah ma passion par le manga est
arrivé d'abord parler non pas par le
livre mais pas des épisodes animés donc
faire la télé ma passion aussi pour
l'hôtellerie pour le monde du luxe et
autres de des palaces qui m'ont amené
vers la cuisine plus tard ben j'ai
découvert par la télé et petit à petit
tous que tout ce que je connaissais pas
moi attendant brillé avec avec tout ce
qu'on pouvait avoir comme mélange
culturel au final bah je les trouvais
dans l'intérêt moi je voudrais revenir
au moment où vous êtes donc en fin de
troisième et on vous demande de me
tailler de décider un peu du mythique
vous avez envie de faire et là vous
optez pour le bep cuisine c'est pourquoi
pourquoi on va souvent demandé cette
question et c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
moi j'ai j'aurais pu aller en général et
quand il va prendre le temps de choisir
une orientation servile niveau le niveau
pour continuer sur une générale mais
j'ai envie de découvrir un métier et je
vais je vais faire quelque chose et même
en fait aux fidèles et la cuisine je me
suis lancé dessus moi en me disant
pourquoi pas j'ai toujours adoré cet
univers de l'hôtellerie j'ai toujours
été en tout cas très curieux de ce qui
s'y passait
l'univers dans tout cet univers de
l'hôtellerie la partie qui me plaisait
plus c'était la cuisine et je me suis
dit bon essayons pour voir mais c'était
vraiment pourquoi pas et alors ça va
très vite marché parce que votre premier
cours de cuisine je crois est une
révélation vous vous le demande de
brider une volaille un bleu je vous ai
découvert ce que ça voulait dire en
préparant cette émission et là vous
faites ça bien je crois et votre prof
vous félicite et là il ya quelque chose
qui se passe est un déclic quoi oui un
déclic à ce moment là où au début du
cours je comprenais pas trop pourquoi
j'avais une aiguille un fils et un
poulet je comprenais pas du tout ce que
je devais faire oui mais ça veut dire
quoi alors bris d une valeur d une volée
en fait c'est là comme la coudre en fait
pour qu'ils se maintiennent bien la
cuisson donc on passe avec un fils de
boucher et l'aiguillât et puis on
fait en sorte qu'à celles bien pour la
cuisson et donc ben apparemment je
l'avais bien fait
absolument parce que choisir j'aurais
voté je sais j'ai ce qui nous montrait
et au final quand on arrivait à la fin
donc j'avais brider ses poulets qu'on
avait cuit qu'on avait déposé dans
l'assiette et autres bois et cette
petite fierté en fait un peu de
l'artisan du fait que bah c'est moi qui
les fais quoi et en plus on félicite et
en plus c'est bon et je pense que tout
de suite j'ai été accro à 7 à cette
petite fierté c'est ça qui va vous
plaire c'est d'abord un retour immédiat
sur votre oeuvre en fait sur deux soit
tout de suite vous faites quelque chose
vous êtes féliciter et vous savez tout
de suite que c'est bien vous avez
peut-être un don aussi puisque vous êtes
félicite tout de suite bas sans l avoir
passé j'ai un bon mais en tout cas j'ai
j'ai tout de suite apprécié j'ai tout de
suite réussi à me concentrer sur ce que
je faisais et la concentration dans
notre métier c'est très important de
pouvoir sauter richesse parce qu on n et
coll il ya une école on apprend beaucoup
de connaissances mais aussi une école du
geste et le geste on
on arrive à la voir qu'en répétant en
répétant et au final avoir cette
patience et cette concentration pour
répéter le même geste 100 200 fois
jusqu'à l'avoir parfaitement c'est pas
tout le monde qui a envie de le faire
respectivement de caunes est capable au
final mais vous qui connaissez si peu la
cuisine française les produits français
j'imagine que vous avez découvert des
choses des produits que vous ne
connaissez même pas des goûts vous ne
connaissez même pas ça n'a pas été un
handicap jamais bas c'était un handicap
30 secondes en battant
demandé est ce que vous connaissez cette
recette banon première fois que j'en
entends parler à ce moment là oui on
sent un peu m mais après tout de suite
derrière moi je suis extrêmement curieux
et pour moi c'était tous les jours une
découverte qu'au final quand je suis
arrivé un fenouil jamais mangé toi nous
lis je ne savais même pas ce que c'était
vraiment je passais devant
dans les étals je vais effets de lumière
franchement savais pas ce que c'était
qu'un feu de vert allemand est donc la
première fois il a fallu travailler le
fenouil j'ai même pas passé par le coupé
quel goût ça et finale bat mois au lieu
de le prendre comme quelque chose je
prend des rebonds j'ai laissé passer on
va voir comment ça se passe non je
voulais vraiment découvrir et y aller
donc au final ça a nourri ma curiosité
pendant ces deux ans du bp j'ai appris
énormément et je demandais même plus à
savoir comment depuis quand les
différents titres finalement voir vrille
et donc il y avait l'effet de surprise
qui dit que vous étiez seront plus
motivés que les autres quoi cgt j'étais
hyper car il ya de tout et moi c'était
vraiment un ces jets comme un gosse dans
un parc d'attractions quoi je découvrais
plein de choses et au final je pense que
ça m'a beaucoup aidé dans mon
apprentissage et puis évidemment ce qui
va être déterminant pour la suite de
votre carrière ce sont les rencontres
avec des grands chefs
chacun j'ai l'impression était
déterminant pour des choses différentes
peut-être commençons par hans wanner
qu'est ce qui vous a appris lui bat lui
il m'a appris en fait il m'a permis
d'avoir le deuxième déclic gérait
jusqu'ici j'ai je faisais mon métier
j'ai aimé mon métier je faisais plutôt
bien mais je pouvais pas me définir
comme passionné j'étais beaucoup plus
passionné par les résultats du psg
que les étoiles du guide quoi par
exemple
je vais pas me définir comme fasciné par
ce métier est lui à ce moment là je sais
pas pourquoi je sais pas comment mais il
m'a pas lâché m'a dit écoute maurice tu
progresser dans ce métier il faut
vraiment que je mette la tête dedans que
que tu vois qu est-ce que les grands
chefs font qu'elles sont les plats comme
en rien des ses plats et l'a eu l'idée
d'organiser comme des petits testing onu
des bombes à témoin cette fois tu me
fais un plat et puis si ça me plaît
passera au plat du jour et à ce moment
là bas moi je me suis pris au jeu et je
me souviens j'avais fait un canard et
patates douces et framboises et il a
adoré ce plat et
mais pour faire ce plat moi j'avais dû
bosser quand j'avais bossé koala est
renseigné je voulais faire une purée de
patates douces j'ai été voir la furie de
robuchon pommes de terre et autres et en
fait je pense qu'ils savaient très bien
ce qu'ils faisaient mais moi en me
renseignant sur ce pour faire ce plat
j'ai mis un peu le doigt dans
l'engrenage et depuis je peux me définir
vraiment comme un passionné de cuisine
ce que j'étais pas à vendre c'est déclic
est arrivé avec lui et puis il ya une
autre rencontre déterminante c'est
thierry marx évidemment lui vous apprend
à penser un plat à penser la cuisine
c'est ça c'est ça il m'a on va dire il
finalise ma formation il me fait passer
de cuisiniers h/f au final donc il
m'apprend à penser un plat et m'apprend
à réfléchir qu'est-ce que je mets dans
l'assiette pourquoi je les mets dans
l'assiette et comment je pose dans
l'assiette mais au final c'est des
questions moi je cuisinais je faisais
des choses bonnes mais voilà quoi mais
sans plus mais lui me disait mais écoute
3 bouchier c'est assez mais ce condiment
les très bons mais si tu mets la moitié
en fait ça ton plat sera meilleur que si
tu le mets tout entier et c'est cette
réflexion en fait au final 17
intellectualisation de la cuisine que
moi j'avais pas jusqu'ici qui m'a
apporté c'est comment on pense à cuisine
comment on développe les plats et
comment
comment d'un plat bon on va aller
chercher quelque chose de très très bon
et c'est une réflexion que plein de gens
n'ont pas effectué de zecs la cuisine
c'est plus qu'un savoir faire et des
gestes en fait c'est une réflexion de
sas et on ne pense pas tout le temps
mais il ya une vraie réflexion donc
comment construire un plat est ce qu'on
a envie de voir sa texture est ce qu'on
veut un texture est ce qu'il ya une
balance entre la mer et sucrés ou au
contraire est-ce que je veux juste et
l'amertume je l'assumé il va falloir
quelque chose derrière pour venir
l'arrondir et c'est toutes ces choses là
et en fait au final pour un plat on peut
on peut y penser pendant deux semaines
trois semaines et on testing les tarifs
ou de l'extérieur et vous vous êtes en
chef comment vous êtes quelle sorte de
chef bah moi je pense que je suis un
chef j'ai déjà mon époque
et avec les autres elle avec les autres
d'en bas c'est aussi parce que j'étais à
l'école dé thierry marx au final mais
moi je prenais un management qui est qui
et résume un final où on va accompagner
nos collaborateurs je veux pas moi le
ramener ma vision et leur imposer ma
vision je veux qu'ils y adhèrent et qui
me suivent et que surtout sensible de
pouvoir proposer des choses aussi parce
que pour moi j'ai autant que chef j'ai
autant apprendre d'un comique de chef de
parti que dans ce chef qui sont à
différents échelons en dessous de moi
mais peuvent tous m'apporter quelque
chose et c'est cette ouverture que j'ai
envie d'avoir où je me dis je vais le
voir mon ca j allais dire tiens est ce
que tu fais moi un plat fais moi quelque
chose
dis moi c'est un plat quelque chose que
tu aimerais essayé et je veux qu'ils
sentent libres de pouvoir essayer et au
final de cet échange déjà le gagne en
confiance donc de détecter peut-être un
futur mûri sakho bah ouais cherchez vous
essayez toi bah moi j'avais détectée je
n'ai pas détecté je recherchais n'ont
pas encore enfin encore mais justement
moi ce que ce qui me ce que j'adore
c'est de pouvoir voir les gens grandir
avec moi et puis aussi prendre confiance
et développer leurs mains et le seco
finale petit à petit ils arriveront eux
mêmes à trouver leur propre voie et ça
c'est important c'est à dire que l'on
fait un bout de chemin avec moi mais au
bout d'un moment ils vont avoir besoin
de s'affirmer et de faire leur propre
cuisine vous parlez du management
bienveillant qui vient de l'école
thierry marx ça veut dire qu'il ya
d'autres écoles et quand on vient de
l'extérieur on est tous un peu surpris
par ce vocabulaire chef oui chef c'est
quand même un peu militaire une cuisine
vous avez rencontré des chefs plus dur
où vous avez eu connaissance de
situations plus difficiles dans des
cuisines où il ya une forme de
maltraitance d'humiliation vous l'avez
vécu vous même ou entendu bah moi j'ai
une chance c'est que dans mon parcours
j'ai jamais vécue jamais de cuisine ou
les des violences outre donc ça je pense
que c'est une chance d'accord après faut
pas se voiler la face bien sûr que ça
existe dans notre métier des chefs qui
sont plus durs les chefs qui ils ont
besoin d'être très très très derrière
leur équipe et avec une ambiance qui est
pas du tout agréable pour ceux qui
travaillent mais après moi j'ai une
certitude c'est que tous les chefs de ma
génération tout ce que je connais qui
sont des amis ou pas du tout d'ailleurs
mais ont tous à coeur de ne pas répéter
ce système que je pense que notre
génération de chefs avons connu et on a
tous envie de créer une rupture là
dessus c'est à dire ok stop parce que
c'est plus possible de bosser comme ça
au final on fait un métier qui est
magnifique et engage tous en fête avec
des contes et des comportements comme ça
dans qui est ni un ego fort des chefs
veulent une ancienne génération
peut-être pas de lame autres mais non
mais un problème d'ego s'était gaussé un
moteur parce que forcément un mégot bon
on arrive à donner plus à aller chercher
plus à aller chercher plus de
distinction et au final c'est un moteur
qui est formidable mais derrière il ya
tout ce qui est négatif derrière et
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d'ego dans
ce métier et que l'ego n'arrange pas les
choses parce que final à force de mettre
une personne sur un piédestal
on peut vite se croire tout puissant
alors c'est pas le cas on a juste un
restaurant et les gens travaillent pour
un salaire mais ils sont pas voués à
nuuk quoi donc aussi ça à prendre en
considération mais on sent que les egos
en train de redescendre été
tourné dans la cuisine fait ça c'est
important c'était vraiment nécessaire
c'est en train de se faire petit à petit
au fur et à mesure des générations mais
moi je vois que tous les jeunes qui
sortent de l'école maintenant sont
absolument pas prêts à accepter ça et
donc au final
soit soit ces chefs vont évoluer soit
ils vont disparaître mais au final ça se
faire tout seul brissac aux gets in
archives pour vous parce que votre
culture c'est pas forcément pas
seulement la france et l'afrique vous en
avez une autre et vous allez comprendre
en voyant ce document qui nous a été
confiée par les archives nationales nos
partenaires c'est une estampe japonaise
qui nous montre la rencontre entre deux
jeunes guerriers sur le pont gojo uchiwa
camaro et benkei et leur rencontre
commence par une bataille va devenir par
une amitié éternelle c'est une histoire
devenue un récit extrêmement populaire
au japon c'est l'équivalent chez nous de
roland et olivier ce qui m'amène à vous
parler de cette passion pour le japon
qui vous vient tout bien personne france
japon ou bien par le manga ouai donc je
suis à force comme beaucoup de ma
génération j'ai fait un délai manga la
télé fox était de nick et daft punk et
des survivants et les autres c'est très
très vieux
et depuis tout jeune j'ai toujours été
passionné parfois donc après c'est
devenu one piece et dragon ball naruto
est haute mais ça m'a toujours ça va
toujours versée et en grandissant finale
de cette passion juste pour les anime et
manga s'est développé une passion pour
la culture japonaise au sens large donc
le mode de vie japonais et puis après
par mon métier la gastronomie japonaise
mais tout est venue du manga au final
qu'est ce qu'elle a de particulier cette
gastronomie japonaise du coup qu'est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle apporte à vos
plats qu'est ce que vous allez chercher
qu'il n'y a pas ni dans la cuisine ouest
africaine ni dans la cuisine française
badens eux dans cette usine japonaise
est une forme de d'abord d'élégance mais
il ya surtout d'humilité en fête finale
qui va faire énormément dans la cuisine
japonaise dans dans l'esprit la cuisine
kaiseki japonaises ont dit que le
meilleur chef le maire cuisinier c'est
lui dans la main se voit pas donc au
final les cuisiniers s'efface totalement
derrière son produit intéressant
c'est tout l'inversé c'est tout l'un
vers sa finale et là dessus c'est en est
sûr ne sur une contradiction totale avec
la gastronomie française et moi je
trouve que c'est la chose la plus
magnifique au final deux y'a bon moi je
suis chef je vais préparer ce plat mais
je m'efface totalement derrière mon
produit parce que le produit
exceptionnel et s'expriment dé lui même
mais vous avez dire jours dans une
interview la cuisine française c'est
celle de l'édition et la cuisine
japonaise c'est celle de la soustraction
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire dans un
plat pas dans un plat on va dire si on
prend l'exemple d'une chartreuse bon ah
le con cuisine française on va prendre
une carotte on va la taille est d'accord
on va la cure bons valables en chêne
première fois ensuite on va faire une
farce mousseline comme un mètre à
l'intérieur et on va caler tout petit
tout autour puis on va là récurrents
vapeur puis après on va associer avec
une sauce plus plus d'elle si des choses
ont changé après ça peut être très bon à
la fin ça soit assez fait pour être très
bon à la fin mais on ajoute en ajoutant
ajouté et c'est cuisine japonaise
justement par exemple on gagne sur un
bouillon sur un bouillon dashi on va
voir où on va demander aux chefs quel
est l'élément le plus important va nous
dire l'eau parce qu'au final il ya de
l'eau une algue et du poisson fumé et
tout ce qui va faire la différence entre
les différents types de dalles chivas
est l'amant du cuisinier et ses
savoir-faire au final est-ce que je
laisse infuser une nuit 2h 3h et la
différence de goût et la nuance
vacheries que là dessus donc au final on
retire tous les ingrédients pour garder
que l'essentiel
c'est ça et ça peut être sept se fade en
fait au final peu vu cette faveur en
fait à des gens pour chercher des fois
japon oui mais c'est vrai que sur les
cuisines et sa gastronomie française ou
d'afrique oui ce que j'ai pas de faveur
il n'y a pas de fadeur nom et donc au
final c'est justement là où on peut
considérer comme un point faible des
saisies et son amie japonaise va on va
aller chercher le point fort dans
d'autres cuisines et d'en étudier
africaine et l'a amené un goût qui sera
beaucoup plus puissant et le plus
d'intensité donc moi quand le faire des
recettes japonaise même mené japonais
aux réformes des droits on connaît la
recette mais avec cette force donc
j'aurais tendance à pousser tous les to
les traceurs il est allé au japon
non j'ai invité ses frères il faut y
aller oui oui j'ai peur de parvenir mais
j'ai bien y aller ça alors j'ai des
photos pour vous
j'ai plusieurs photos à proposer elles
sont censées vous parlez en tout cas
vous inspirer des shows dont celle là
facile hein c'est 1 2 dans l'émission
top chef cette émission de m6 qui vous
l'a révélé au grand public
vous lui devez beaucoup j'imagine vous
avez dit un jour elle m'a fait gagner 5
à 10 ans sur ma cuisine cette émission
ce cas une exigence incroyables c'est ça
il ya une exigence incroyables et on se
rend pas compte mais pour un cuisinier
delà de l'âge auquel ont participé au
moment de la carrière auquel on
participe on n'a jamais l'occasion de
faire déguster sa cuisine à autant de
chefs au final et on a un retour
immédiat de ces chefs donc je fais un
plat et l'âge et pierre gagnaire trois
étoiles enfin trois étoiles 18 et toi je
crois dans l'aude qui juge ma cuisine et
qui me fait un retour en direct et sans
le répète par le nombre d'épreuves qu'on
fait et au final on progresse énormément
parce qu'on voit qu'ils ont des valeurs
communes des manières d'analyser
d'assiette qui sont différentes mais au
final ils cherchent tous les mêmes
tracés et si on arrive à garder ça en
tête bon au final on gagne cinq à dix
ans parce que avant d'avoir ce déclic
tout seul dans sa cuisine bas le temps
parce qu on vous sent heureux en tout
cas dans ses cuisines vous auriez envie
de faire partie des chefs juge cette
fois le jury un jour pourquoi pas c'est
marrant à faire moi ces émissions que
j'ai adoré faire et c'est un programme
qui pour moi a changé beaucoup notre
métier auquel on doit beaucoup à la
pelle à m6 alors une deuxième photo
maurice rico c'est un livreur de plats
commandés sur internet on parlait du coc
vie toute alliance avec beaucoup de gens
se sont mis à préférer manger chez eux
plutôt qu'au restaurant comme d'ailleurs
à regarder des films plutôt que d'aller
au cinéma il ya une forme de sédentarité
qui s'installe est aussi associé un peu
parfois à la malbouffe alors vous vous
en vous avez fait aussi un système de
livraison à domicile vous avait rebondi
au moment de ce qu vide et vous avez
fait aussi des plats à emporter un je
crois ouais totalement mais moi j'ai
fait des plats emporté parce que
justement et en plus on n'a pas fait la
cuisine de mousse kg pas voulu faire les
gastronomique à emporter j'ai vraiment
voulu faire du street food pouvoir
parler le plus de monde possible et sur
cette idée justement du street food moi
je pense que les chefs en europe
justement pas laisser ce terrain des
industriels parce qu'au final peu vont
le faire mais ils vont le faire avec des
produits et des instits ifs et autres et
justement ça nous chef d'aller sur ce
terrain proposé une alternative street
food mais dans des prix abordables l'on
dit prêt à voir dame ça parce que c'est
la clé vous êtes d'accord on reste
toujours un peu au dessus parce que
quand on achète un bon produit bas on
est un peu au dessus mais nous on va
dire sur l'offre avec le plat la boisson
et un dessert avec un accompagnement en
était à 19 euros ce qui reste accessible
pour tout le monde vous arriver à
toucher d'autres publics que ceux qui
sont des habitués des grands restos
c'est ça c'est ça ça allait toucher
d'autres publics soient revues que ceux
habitués des grands restos et un public
aussi forcément plus jeunes et un public
qui n'aurait pas les moyens de se payer
les gastronomies donc c'est sympa aussi
de pouvoir proposer l'offre à ce public
différent et peut-être enfin ceux qui
habitent au bout du rer
cela peut aussi avoir un peu un peu un
peu de chefs et pour un prix qui paie
des impôts batave n'est qu'une question
rituelle là encore dans cette émission
on est entouré de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu on a la
sagesse derrière vous la prudence ici je
crois la justice et l'éloquence derrière
moi à laquelle de ces vertus vous auriez
envie de
2,2 vous identifier là maintenant tout
de suite cela qu'elle vous parle la
sagesse la prudence la justice
l'éloquence
j'aimerais que ce soit la sagesse je
fais
faire vite pour atteindre la sagesse
c'est qu'on a déjà bien vécu
voilà on va s'arrêter sur ses jolies mon
médecin fini mon sac ou d'avoir été
notre invité dans ce dom tournant au
sénat dans un monde un regard merci
d'avoir fait partager votre regard sur
le monde et votre monde merci infiniment
à vous de nous avoir suivi et à très
bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]